Mobile games landscape
has been changing faster than ever.
With millions of new Android users coming online
especially in the emerging markets
such as Southeast Asia and Latin America
it’s become essential to understand the market
and ride the next growth wave.
My name is Derek Oh
I’m the Vice President
of Business Development at Netmarble.
Netmarble was established in 2000 in South Korea
as a PC online game developer and publisher.
Around 2011
we pivoted to mobile gaming
and have a series of mega hit titles
Lineage 2 Revolution is a top PC online game in Korea
and its mobile version was a blockbuster hit
since its day 1 launch in December 2016.
For us Indonesia is a top priority market
because of the huge user base
and growing smartphone adoption.
Since the essence  of MMORPG is community
we made the game, store listing
and also the customer care
completely localised in Bahasa.
We also introduced “Barong”
an Indonesian character, in the game play
to connect with the gamers.
Our biggest challenge
was tackling the low IP awareness.
One month pre-launch
we used Google Play's pre-registration feature
amplifying this with marketing and an on-site showcase.
We also launched Netmarble’s
Indonesian channel on Youtube
to connect with our audiences better.
For post-launch
we focused on developing the right partnerships
and with Google’s help
our local partners like
Telkomsel, GO-JEK, Indomaret and Tokopedia
have played crucial roles
to maintain our post-launch momentum.
We had a very successful launch in Indonesia.
We received 1.5 million pre-registrations
and the game hit number 1 on the gross ranking chart
on the first day of the launch.
and the game still remains top 10 today.
We already knew how important the localization
and having the right marketing strategy was
but the success in Indonesia
reinforced the importance of it.
Netmarble’s moto is to create fun games
for global gamers
and we are doing our best to make that happen.